I think I'm scared of like as vulnerable
as I can be like on the podcast and talk
about [__] like letting go and losing
control and crying and stuff like that
that scares me baby scary but that's
what you need you know what I mean
because you think you're in control you
think because you're holding this thing
together you're in control right that's
what it's creating all these problems
we're not in control we're afraid
do you know yeah I've had a couple of
about a year this is great but we're
good right you're watching it this is
good [__] okay it's cut by the way cut
me off no [__] this is exactly what I
want I'm like oh this is Kevin I had uh
a year ago my my one of my best friends
was my manager his name is Chris euvane
uh his brother's Kevin euvane who runs
CAA like very prominent family killed
himself shot him spoke to him on the
phone he was going through depression
serious depression uh we were gonna take
him to a new facility on on Monday very
successful manager Chadwick Boseman
Margot Robbie like this guy was this
[__]
everyone loved this kid right had
everything to live for and uh so I spoke
to him the night before he killed
himself and I said I'm taking you to
Peter uh this this Thursday he was
coming back
he killed himself the next day right
oh devastating gutted like took six
months for me to recover so I could even
function this guy I spoke to him 30
times a day but he was very vocal about
being depressed right and he couldn't he
could not get a hold of it he couldn't
so I it's the first time I've witnessed
what mental health mental sickness
mental illness really is do you know
what I mean this guy had all the money
in the world very powerful came from a
family that was runs Hollywood and was
beloved you know helped everybody paid
it first and wasn't happy wasn't happy
right beyond happy like joyless
which is worse like going through the
motions of life and and and and being
vocal about not getting anything back
from it do you know what I mean yeah so
six months go by and I have I grew up in
a house with my father's brother's kids
too we all grew up together so there was
there was eight of us all mostly all
boys there was only two girls and and um
my closest cousin who I grew up with my
it was my brother was getting divorced
blah blah blah girl moved to Montana
kids to California Montana long story
comes to my house on a Thursday and he's
down right he just turned 60. uh and he
was really down
um and I I I uh oh no a week before he
came to my house I sent him to Peter
he came out of Peter and he said I don't
know what that is he said but I've never
felt like this in my life I have a clear
path
to what I need to do and I'm going to go
to Montana and tell Pauline and I'm
going to stay in California and I think
I I gotta hang thank you so much and
Peter had called me and then he came to
my house the following week and he was
going to Montana he went to Montana and
he's very vulnerable very an empathic
guy and she was not kind to him and
she she said some things to him and he
killed himself the same way that my
friend Chris did shot himself
and that oh my God is that so much loss
well and in a specific way like mental
illness and that put me on a path
to
help anybody and everybody like if you
who I don't know told me just now that
you were going through some like
whatever I can do to help any stranger
who tells me that they're suffering
that's kind of been my thing
um I don't know how I got off on this
team no but are you talking about your
friend's death yeah killing himself
you're talking about the breathing yeah
how that you're about to get him into
that and then this happened right before
which is devastate you know it's so
funny because I've talked about this but
doing this podcast I I wasn't uh you
know somebody's like you got a great
voice you should do podcasts man you
should have your own you know interview
celebrity so make money I'm like all
right cool and I started doing it I was
like man no one's really listening no
one's you know and I was just kind of
like you know whatever and then I
started to be vulnerable
and I start to speak openly spoke openly
about my depression anxiety my life
everything yeah and get started open up
crying everything and now I just went to
a con in in Chicago I don't even promote
the con or promote the podcast one of my
cons or anything right
if I told you how many people came up to
me saying
it means so much to me your podcast I'm
like and I'm like why Wow but hearing
other people that have had huge success
right and them all being vulnerable and
them being like hey you know I and it
just helps so many people when you just
talk about it that's right